once again we've reached the start of a
new year but before we say goodbye to
2022 completely I gotta say
we got some pretty great anime didn't we
[Music]
2022 was a year of Heavy Hitters in
almost every genre of anime massively
anticipated titles finally dropping and
having the impact we thought they were
big franchises continuing to another
season and hitting even harder we even
got old franchises getting resurrected
and looking better than ever 2022 was
absolutely stacked but what else
happened in the world for us weebs after
25 years Ash finally broke his curse by
becoming the Pokemon world champion knew
so big it was reported like a real
sporting event as the world celebrated
allowing him to finally retire at the
ripe old age of 11. Italy had a
surprising visitor as a certain
promiscuous video of Tifa Lockhart was
accidentally played at their Senate
prompting the only time you'll ever see
Italians more passionate than their
Pastor when asking for the source this
forever immortalized FIFA in Italy law
becoming only the second person since
Julius Caesar to be violently stabbed at
a senate in Rome all right what else was
there I uh got the climax to the biggest
romance Arc of my own life
gone
2022 was a bit of a quiet year in terms
of anime news we didn't get any
particularly big Shockers or
controversies even anime didn't give us
any wildly bad stinkers compared to
previous years but what we got instead
was some bloody great anime this year
was brutally hard to narrow down my list
of favorites so don't spend two months
making an hour long video normally I try
to emit sequels and continuations unless
it does something new or notable for me
to talk about which makes it messy
because so many of them did this year
this is going to be the longest list in
a while so I had to be Cutthroat if I
didn't have much to say My Hero season 6
is the best my hero has been in a long
time but still not quite good enough yet
JoJo had his hype murdered by Netflix
but is still more great JoJo bleacher's
return has been an absolutely incredible
sight to witness I'd forgotten bleach
could get this hype but the last time it
talks in depth about the OG big three
this happened and I don't want to risk
that for a video this big Attack on
Titan is also continuing to stamp its
markdown on anime history we got more
incredible twists more incredible hype
more of Aaron being like like must you
killed a child
amazing mission complete that right
there is why you're the best boss I'm
just waiting for it to finally learn
what the word final means in final
season before I fully pass judgments
which is why I'm glad this next season
is called Attack on Titan final season
the final Edition
part one
let's just get started but before moving
on to all the great shows last year who
doesn't love a good snack while watching
some great anime well today's sponsor
has got you covered because it's boxu
guys if you know anything about Japan
you know the food here is Godly and boxu
is my favorite Japanese snack box they
work with local businesses from all over
the country to bring you the best
Japanese snacks every single month and
as you can see this month we're getting
a super special pretty box because
Sakura season is almost upon us yes this
month's theme is Sakura in Kyoto I'm
gonna be honest one of the hardest parts
of being sponsored by boxers I have to
actually wait to try out these snacks on
camera instead of just opening up and
trying out straight when I receive it
alright let me see what looks good this
month I have not had a Sakurai flavored
Mochi yet so let's see what this tastes
like oh that smells really good
that's pretty damn good I'm sad there's
only one of those in the Box this one is
the Kyoto Sable umer I always love the
different types of biscuits they send me
and I'm excited to try this one
oh this is dangerous thank God there are
two in these because I was afraid they
were just one honestly guys top tier
snacks every single time this box is
gonna be entirely gone by the end of the
day each box is completely packed and it
comes with a booklet that teaches you
all about the snacks unique flavor and
where they come from so guys if you want
to introduce yourself to Japanese food
culture or just find the perfect gift
for your fellow weebs boxu has got you
covered and this is pretty much perfect
for all the shows gonna be talking about
if you want to snap on something so what
are you waiting for click that link in
the description and use code Geiger cat
checkout for 15 off your first box you
purchase thank you very much to the Box
view for sponsoring me this month back
to the video
[Music]
yeah close enough when I think about
watching golf I think
golf is one of those things I love to
play but when I watch it you'd have a
better chance of waking up a coma
patient so birdie win came in with a
Monumental task of tackling The
Impossible problem how do we make golf
fun to watch
gay girls in it not golf enough for you
how about we add special golf attacks
golf with guns an underground golf
syndicate with golf settle Kaiba in golf
battle City where golfers have a golf
duel to the death one moment you can be
watching a girl driving a ball through a
moving train now the next dude is being
assassinated on Highway via rocket
launcher this anime is about as anime as
anime gets and if you're willing to give
it a chance it will golf you so hard you
will be golfed into submission this was
a bloody wild ride from start to finish
and by the end of it you'll be excitedly
singing along to the catchy opening
every time
[Music]
every season we get one or two new anime
with the stupidest [__] concept of
all time like they had a dartboard of
random ideas that they tried to crash
into each other and going hi guys what
if this works what's incredible is when
it actually does but if you call me or
your boy Kong Ming yes that's the
official translated title asks what
happens if legendary Chinese tactician
juga Liang gets reward to modern day
Tokyo to become the manager of an EDM
Idol and leads the girl to stardom using
the Art of War it's an absurd idea that
looks even more absurd on screen but all
it took was one look at the opening for
me to go you son of a [__] I'm in it
instantly grabs you with this infectious
charm and holds on tight whether you're
seeing a breakdown of how ancient war
tactics can be used to gain Twitter
followers or watching a historic Chinese
figure spitting some fire bars in a rap
battle I know what you're already
jokingly typing best rapper since Eminem
wrong yeah Eminem's alright but has he
ever roasted a dude so hard he [__]
diesel
foreign
oh damn it but past the business it
never forgets the beating Hearts behind
it like Kong Ming we're cheering for
every step closer Aiko takes towards
stardom her journey into music was so
well done you forget the absurdity of
the premise and that's the real heart of
the show because I can't even begin to
describe the unbridled satisfaction of
cheering for this girl to succeed and by
the end seeing her move closer to
achieving her dream weight
did I just get tricked into watching an
idol anime
[Music]
yeah Keanu Reeves is cool but have you
ever sat there and asked yourself is
there anything we can possibly do to
make John Wick even better gay girls in
it licorice recoil takes a simple
approach you like cute girls you like
guns we're gonna give cute girls some
guns so what happens if you are
beautifully adorable anime girls into a
gun-toting spy action thriller well you
get something like this
Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne somehow
we have a show that attempts to straddle
the perfect Middle Ground between Moe's
Slice of Life and hardcore action you
have a dark terrorist plot line where
the stakes of high people are getting
murdered there are intense gunfights
straight out of a Max Payne game and
then we cut to a scene where the girls
are like
oh this is also beyond the list if not
for giving us the most precious Duo to
come out of 2022 but if you're still
like okay but house is any better than
John Wick well um
yeah if I need your body I'll [__] it
[Music]
Marin is still the best girl of 2022.
it's not because she reminds me of my
wife hey
picture
[Music]
which was a blessing because we got not
one but two great football anime
introducing weebs to the wonderful
experience of watching a bit of footy at
the pub no don't just you can't miss
this you can't miss
oh she was probably the most overlooked
Sports Anime this year production IG
just kill it every freaking time they do
a sports show and this was no exception
showcasing the high quality they've done
before with haikyu and Kuroko and
bringing that hype to football then blue
lock came along and went look at this
baby [__] now this is real football none
of that friendship [__] we're doing
a football Battle Royale where the
entire point is being selfish and
egotistical this broke every cardinal
rule previous Sports Anime had set up
and was some of the most fun I had all
year but you know what was more anime
than both these anime this year the
World Cup itself baby upset after upset
we had the hype we had the drama we had
one of the greatest World Cup finals of
all time Messi securing his status as
the absolute goats and buppy carrying
France Boeing 747 carrying Belgium and
Germany England being Harry Kane penalty
is inevitable he scores a hundred times
out of a hundred
England Japan keeping the ball one
millimeter in play to score the winning
goal against Spain just what the hell
were the scriptwriters thinking yeah
this was actually the best sports anime
of the Year [__] these other two that is
not passion there is no vision there is
no aggression in this Football Club
Stellar action compelling plot lines
interesting characters all reasons we
watch the anime we do but I ask you can
a show be worth watching solely for
vibes
yes call of the night is the anime that
speaks to the soul of anyone who's ever
been a night owl in their lives I'm
talking to you yes you come on it's 3am
we're in [__] d-gen hours now what
are you still doing awake watching
YouTube videos
Liam there's just something comforting
about wondering the normally bustling
streets in the dead at night unless
you're in America and this is the
feeling call of the night perfectly
captures cityscapes Dazzle you the empty
streets invite you in as a gentle
soundtrack sues you win to the um that's
enough now it's time to go to sleep yeah
all those people who called me a
sleepwalker I woke up now I'm going back
to sleep
[Music]
every year there's always a gem of an
anime that gets Stripped Away of all the
potential hype it could have had because
it's in the jail of some streaming
platform that doesn't promote it and
this year there was no bigger tragedy
than summertime render being locked
behind Disney plus what do you get if
you cross re-zero with a mock higarashi
this show a dude returns home on an
island to attend a friend's funeral but
something's off people are acting
strange something doesn't quite add up
to the events of his friend's death but
no one wants to talk about it there's an
air of unease that something terrifying
is going on behind the scenes then
before you can even begin to paint a
picture of what Horrors are really lying
underneath
he dies
that was episode one this is the kind of
show that pulls you in from its opening
episode and refuses to ever let go it
shows us the stakes and never gives us a
moment to Breathe It presents you with
this intriguing mystery solves it in two
episodes and gives you 10 more only to
do the same thing over again you're
constantly on your toes and just as soon
as you think you've figured out the
rules of the game boom it hits you with
a new twist that changes everything
twist breast milk it will keep you
guessing keep you thinking all the way
up to the final episode and the only big
criticism I can lay against it is that I
need to give Disney my hard-earned money
to watch it did somebody mention the
door to Darkness
[Music]
one thing I've learned about the anime
Community is the more popular a show is
the cooler you get for calling it mid so
here you go Demon Slayer season 2 is mid
way between great and bloody fantastic
and also Midway up your mum it doesn't
have the most complex characters it
doesn't have the most original plots but
whatever it doesn't have it makes up for
in pure undistilled hype if actions
speak louder than words Demon Slayer is
[__] screaming the Entertainment
District art reaches an audio visual
experience few anime series can ever
match raising the bar for Studio UFO
tables already insanely high standards
when you tell UFO table that your amp
goes up to 11 they go yeah that's q and
turns there's up to 30. an adaptation
like this shows that even people at the
top of their field can strive to improve
their craft because what they've
delivered is an anime with the highest
level of spectacle it can get you hold
your breath waiting for that one
climactic moment it builds and builds
and you're on the edge of your seat
anticipating when that peak's gonna come
and just when you think the hype con
gets even higher it smashes past it to a
point you ever thought it could go your
mind goes blank taking in one of the
most jaw-dropping visual spectacles
anime has ever seen and only then when
everything is said and done do you
remember to take a breath again
laughs
[Music]
family is technically not related by
blood this is the latest in the egg
series where weebs can never agree
whether the x is silent or not and then
there's this one guy I talked last year
that called this spy multiplied by
family
that's not a joke just sulf if you're
watching this what the [__] mate next
time you do that I'm actually calling
the cops going in the show was touted to
me as a gag anime and I'm gonna be
honest I didn't actually find it that
funny but that didn't matter because
every episode left the biggest smile on
my face regardless watching spy X family
reminded me of the types of old school
shows I'd watch with my mum and dad on a
Sunday evening when we'd spend time with
each other the type of show you'd put on
at Christmas that helps bring everyone
together sometimes it's not about having
a super deep interconnected plot line
but a simple story that'll brighten up
your day no matter what and help you
appreciate the family you have around
you
the legacy of Gundam is one of the most
storied and important franchises in all
of anime but with this Legacy and the
sheer number of iterations preceding it
every new Gundam comes in with the
challenge of having to figure out what
can this Gundam do that no other Gundam
has ever done it Gundam the witch from
Mercury is the Gundam we've needed for
the longest time something that wipes
the Slate clean for new fans to be able
to jump in while not forgetting why
people watch Gundam in the first place
it's hard to do a fresh take on such an
old franchise but the wish for mercury
seems to be doing exactly that this is
no war between nations but a war between
corporations here is a world where
profit and power reign supreme Elon Musk
is having a wet dream in a corner the
politics of War have been replaced with
the politics of companies proving that
Corporal drama can be just as gripping
if you add the right conflicts because
Gundam has never been just about the
giant robot fights all right let's talk
about the giant robot fights giant robot
fights are awesome Studio Sunrise have
pulled out all of their expertise to
make this the best looking Mecca show it
can be from the flashiest battle to the
smallest details I mean just listen to
this sound design
now I could have shown you some of this
incredible animation or its orgasmic
music but nobody ever thinks about sound
design and if it can get us to notice
small things like this extrapolate that
to what that means for the rest of the
production values let's just forget
about the fact that there's no sounds in
space though this is AAA production from
top to bottom and it isn't afraid to
flaunt it every episode the witch from
Mercury isn't just here to compete with
other Gundams it isn't just here to
compete with other meccas it's here to
stand Toe to Toe with the best things
out right now if you're new to anime
here if you've never seen a Mecca in
your life and you need a reason to get
it to giant robots this is it
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
every generation we get a genre defining
show one that fans look back on as the
Pinnacle of the genre at that time that
sold them on what could be so great
about it and I believe that kagia summer
has become just that when I started Car
gear I thought it was just going to be
some formulated gagmonger to people that
don't want to confess they find the most
convoluted roundabout way to avoid
confessing and then they don't confess
but what I didn't initially notice is
that even though it seems episodic every
new gag every new skit adds a little bit
more piece by piece a Leia gets added to
each character each of the cast members
it continues to build continues to add
on itself and before you know it it
feels like this group of dimwits have
become your own friends you start to
cherish every single second you get to
put the show on and that's the real
magic of kagia beyond the gags beyond
the Antics it just becomes a joy to
spend time with all of them you fall in
love with this Ensemble so this season
when it follows through and delivers
through the build up we will promise it
results in one one of the most
satisfying climaxes you can find in
Romance Dragon Ball Z Naruto Demon
Slayer attack on Titan these are all
generational anime people talk about as
the shows that introduce them into anime
but once you get past the Shonen Mega
hits you'll find these other shows fans
look back on that served as their
definitive gateways into other genres
without Haruhi I would have never got
into High School anime kogi are stood as
that Mecca show every non-mecca fan
watched I know exactly what generation
you're from if kaon introduced you to
The Slice of Life Moe genre and years
from now kagi of summer is going to be
the anime this new generation of fans
reminisce about when they talk about how
they got into romance anime
chainsaw man came into this year with an
almost impossible amount of hype to meet
but did it rise up to the challenge and
prove us all wrong with this first
season
no but what we got was still pretty damn
good it's been a long time since I've
seen an anime explode onto the scene
this hard and this fast for the
inconceivable expectations it had the
craziest things that it almost stepped
up to the plate to meet them in the
highly popular highly competitive scene
of safe marketable Shonen action shows
it blasted him gave the middle finger
and went [__] you I'ma grab some titties
it's Savage it's out there it's a show
called chainsaw man and it gave us a man
that's a chainsaw what the [__] do we
have to complain about the hype this
show produced could only ever really be
matched by how horny it made the fan
base you got power fans now here's their
perfect girl I too like women who don't
shower don't wipe smells and leave their
logs unflushed why yes how could you
tell I play Super Smash Brothers then
you have the kobeni fans oh yes my wife
was suffering isn't she so adorable
then there's Ximena fans
then there's makama never before has a
character been so perfectly designed so
unequivocally unmatched so incomparably
unparalleled at eliciting the horny if
no not November was an impossible
dungeon she would be the final boss
standing at the end of it every word
every action every line she utters got
you going like my mind's telling me
my body is telling me
on all levels except physical I am a
wolf the real question at the end of
this all was can mappa carry on this
insane quality they've given us with
this adaptation into future Seasons
because it might not have met the hype
this time but after that last episode
when those final credits rolled I had
one thought that engulfed my mind over
everything else we ain't seen nothing
yet
if you know me you know I don't like
Slice of Life I don't like Maui shows I
don't like you girls doing cute things
so believe me when I say that Bocce The
Rock a moe Slice of Life show where cute
girls do cute things is something really
special what makes this so special
gay girls in it way way not this time
but she is a show about this awkward
Gremlin who joins the band and hopes
that she can get over her crippling
social anxiety and achieve the
popularity she never had I know you're
thinking wait I've seen this before it
was called komisan or watamote or
hitoribochi yes what says Bocce apart is
just how above and beyond it goes with
this animation to configure these she's
just like me for real moments characters
go in and off model animators just
[__] give up at times people start
glitching in and out of reality you may
or may not have done the exact same
things that Bocce does but you feel her
in your [__] soul
dinosaur
s
[Music]
[Applause]
of course I was worried that this was
going to be a one-trick pony turns out
it's a tantric Pony in a farm of 100
ponies when you think you get the joke
when you think you know what's coming
the animators hit you with something
completely new that conveys this
terrifyingly relatable feeling in a way
only animation can do this made me laugh
more than any other show this year it
wasn't gut busting laughter it was more
like oh God it felt exactly the same way
God damn it bought you what are you
doing this to me this is triggering my
Firefly response get out of my mind get
out get out get out yeah big mood if
there is a single introvert bone in your
body something in here will drag out a
core memory you've buried deep in the
recesses of your mind like that
intrusive thought that hits you at 3am
and God I didn't even talk about the
music I recently said that this was
everything I was hoping chaon would be
because while yes a lot of this is Slice
of Life Moe you [__] are
getting [__] done
[Music]
around when it comes to their music they
have their goals and they're gonna go
out and achieve it but she may not be
able to form a coherent conversation but
every little step she takes to
overcoming that every time she stepped
up and tears it up on stage made me want
to jump up and go yes that's my girl
this was my biggest surprise of 2022.
bar none in a season of Heavy Hitters
bleach chainsaw man spikes family Bocce
The Rock awkwardly waltzed in grabbed
the mic and went
[Music]
it doesn't matter
cyberpunk 2077 has gone down as one of
the most disastrous launches in gaming
history years of anticipation and build
up led to the release of a broken
unfinished game that would take an equal
amount of years to fix all the bugs that
it had 2077 became a joke a meme Among
The Gaming Community about how not to
launch a game and the biggest praise I
can give to cyberpunk Edge Runners is
that it was so good the anime almost
made everyone forget what happened to
the game
out of nowhere this dropped and
introduced weebs to the insane World Of
Night City we weren't given another
Squeaky Clean safe anime this was some
hardcore dickenbots hyper violent I
[__] your mom kind of show and God
damn was it awesome it hits you with a
story going at Full Throttle from
episode 1 and never takes its foot off
the gas you'll look for a moment to
pause and catch your breath and while
you're waiting you'll realize the
credits to the final episode of rolling
this was the Anime Studio trigger were
born to make that nobody realized they
wanted until now even for a team of
decorated veterans in the industry this
felt like they had upped their game they
felt refreshed revitalized every scene
oozing with style every frame burning
with the passion of everyone working on
it and it's impossible for this
excitement not to get transferred over
to the viewer this is how you do a video
game tie-in and all it took was
emotionally scarring the collective
cyberpunk Community with a single song
foreign
psycho season 3 was announced I remember
saying to myself and we don't need
another season of mob
season 2 was an action-packed
Masterpiece combining some of the best
anime shoot you could ever find with
masterful character writing the series
didn't have before and while I don't
think season three reached those same
Heights it was one that was surely
needed this closed the Final Chapter to
mob's character and everyone around him
in a sense this felt like a season-long
epilogue while I wondered where the
story could go off the season to clear
up all his plot points and defeat the
big evil season 3 took a step back and
went how do we give these characters the
send-offs they deserve Reagan the man so
full of [__] he can sell hamon to a
Stan user ends the series in the most
honest way possible dimple ritsu
hanazawa and most importantly mob for
all the flashy fight scenes that showed
that his true heart lies in the
characters it taught us how to accept
ourselves Through The Eyes of mob's
journey and ended his story in the most
perfect way possible Studio bones can
finally take a bow for the work they've
done here from start to finish mob has
felt like a passion project that has
pushed the boundaries of Animation to
its limits and and Beyond this is the
kind of adaptation everyone only dreams
of and now that we're saying goodbye
whatever your favorite season was it's
hard not to feel like all of mob psycho
has cemented itself as a modern classic
we won't ever forget
[Music]
when I put on a happy movie I know to
come out expecting to feel happy when I
listen to a sad song I know to expect
coming out feeling a bit sad but
sometimes I encounter a piece of media
that leaves me with an emotion that is
utterly Indescribable and that's how
made in the best season two left me it's
been five years since the first Maiden
abyss and now the cat's out of the bag
we know this isn't a cutesy happy show
bad things happen people probably
children are going to suffer and you're
gonna need a good hug by the end of it
all and even knowing this I was not
prepared for the experience this was
gonna give me this is no longer simply
just a sad show or a dark show before
the rules are more simple you go down
deep and maybe you encounter a really
dangerous animal or some crazy evil
person but now the terrorism encounters
cease to follow any logic you're
familiar with we wander around in this
non-usidian world where the laws of the
universe are governed by different
systems the mysteries of the world
refuse to give up its Secrets Eldritch
Horrors lurk around every corner and
your mind can only attempt to comprehend
the nightmares you uncover behind them
made in Abyss 2 contain some of the most
haunting things I've ever seen in anime
but none of it was because of some
simple violence or Gore but ideas and
imagery that disturbs me to my core yet
somehow through all this there's a
gentleness to its story for all its
Terror this is a hauntingly beautiful
tale it gives you hope in a place of
hopelessness then smashes it all away
terrifies you without scaring you and
hits you with the soundtrack that makes
your soul just wails
[Music]
everything
I had an incredibly hard time picking my
favorite anime this year any one of the
top six could have taken the spot but
the reason I settled on Maiden Abyss is
because it's given me an experience like
no other unlike everything else I've
talked about today this has grown Beyond
something I would wholeheartedly
recommend in the same way I don't really
recommend a movie like Requiem for a
Dream because it's not something you go
into to enjoy but if you're brave enough
it's an unfathomably powerful experience
that will haunt you for years to come
best allows you to find beauty in the
horrific hope in the despair you watch
this nightmare unfold through an
ethereal lens it rips your heart to
shreds then gives you a warm hug and
tells you everything's gonna be all
right you go on this ride that tears
your soul apart only to come out smiling
at the other end and only after it's all
over and you sit beside yourself to
process the Journey of emotions you just
felt is there only one word that can
encapsulate it all
wow
[Music]
hey guys hope you're having a great 2023
so far and yeah that was all of my
favorite anime from 2022 and I want to
give a huge 2022 thanks to Alpha Sigma
basil dysfunctional degenerate
flabberwocky I veto Jeff lovados
misaka12315 Payne Patchett Pony Stark
watergeist VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping to support me for
this month and all of last year as well
and also thanks to all of you lot for
sticking with me for another year 2022
has been the most massive year of my
life for a professional and personal
reasons last year was Far and Beyond the
busiest year of our life but somehow I
got through it just fine I don't know
how I did that but here I am but anyway
that's it from me for today hope there's
not too much salt with uh my personal
favorite anime of 2022 there were so
many great shows this year I had a
really really tough time deciding what
was going to be on this list and even
then it's the longest list I've made so
far but anyway hey Happy New Years to
you all and I'll see you guys next time